PROFESSOR: So now,
let's begin talking
about the spread of
disease, initially focusing
on a population of individuals.
So the type of modeling,
which we'll be discussing,
is sometimes referred to
as compartmental modeling
because a population is divided
into different compartments.
Such as, for example, a set
of susceptible people that
have yet not been infected,
a set of infected people,
and finally a compartment
of recovered people.
Additional compartments
could be added, for example,
for different age groups or
sub-populations, for incubation
prior to infection
by the disease,
and, for example, death and
separated from recovery.
This type of modeling based
on population compartments
was introduced by
Kermack and McKendrick
in the simplest case of what
is called the SIR model, where
S is the number of
susceptible, I number infected,
and R the number of recovered
individuals in a population.
And the dynamics
take a simple form
of a set of coupled nonlinear
Ordinary Differential Equations.
So first of all,
the rate of change
of the number of
susceptible people
is minus the transmission
rate beta times S times I
because SI base refers
to how many pairs
of susceptible and individual,
or infected persons there are,
and beta is the transmission
rate per such individual
pair.
And then, next, we look at
the dynamics of the number
of infected persons.
So that starts by a conversion
from susceptible to infected.
So beta*S*I is the rate of
producing new infected persons.
And then, we introduce
another rate, constant gamma,
which is the removal rate.
So this could be
people are removed
from the infected compartment
either by recovering
or, potentially, we could
lump into that, dying.
So we finally complete
the balance here
by writing the number of
recovered, changing as gamma*I.
So basically, we
have a model here
with three compartments
and two rate constants.
Now the important
aspect, really, here
is the rate of change of the
number of infected individuals.
So I'll write that
equation over here, which
is dI/dt equals, and
let's factor out gamma
and write the prefactor
here on the rate
as (beta*S/gamma-1)
times gamma*I.
And if we look now
at early times,
then the number of
susceptible people
is approximately equal to the
initial number, at t=0.
So that's essentially the
size of the entire population,
typically.
And so we would then write this
as beta*S0/(gamma-1),
times gamma*I.
So now this is just a
formula that at early times
gives you an
exponential increase.
So we would then find that I
grows like the initial number
of infected persons.
It could be, for
example, just 1 times
e to this factor here times t.
And I'm going to write it
in a certain way, which
is (R_0-1)*gamma*t.
So this is the early times.
And then we have put
a little squiggle
here to indicate that's
the initial growth
rate or the initial dependence,
where R_0 is beta*S_0/gamma.
And this is called the
reproductive number
of the disease, or
of the epidemic,
because we can see here
that if R_0 is bigger than 1,
then we have an
exponential growth
of the number infected persons.
So then we essentially
have an epidemic
starting from an
initial index case,
or some set of
cases, numbering I_0.
Of course, if R_0 is less than
1, then we have no epidemic.
In other words, there may be
an infected person or two,
but the number will
exponentially decrease,
and there won't be any growth.
So the reproductive number
is an important concept
in epidemiology that comes
directly from these models.
Related to that is the concept
of herd immunity, which
is the point where enough
members of the population
are immune that the
epidemic starts to die
out and eventually disappear.
Let's make a plot of the typical
predictions of the SIR model.
So as a function of time, the
number of susceptible people
starts at some value
S_0, and it decreases.
Initially, the number
of infected persons
starts at some small
number I_0, which
might even just be one index
case, and as we showed here,
it exponentially increases.
The number of
recovered starts at 0
and increases as
well, with some delay
given by the recovery time.
And what we then see is that
as the number of susceptibles
comes down-- let's look
at this equation here.
We can write this as
(beta*S-gamma)*I.
So initially, (beta*S-gamma)
is positive.
It starts, in fact, at the
value (R_0-1)*gamma.
But eventually, as the number of
susceptible people comes down,
there's a certain point
where this factor goes to 0.
And that would be leading
to dI/dt equal to 0.
So, in other words, a maximum of
the number of infected people.
So at some point, there's
going to be a value where
this will turn around.
So dI/dt is equal to zero.
And where that happens will
be at a certain value of S_0,
which we'll just put--
of S, I should say.
I'll call that S_h for the
value of herd immunity
in the susceptible number.
And that is when
this factor
beta*S-gamma is equal to 0.
Or in other words, S_h
is gamma/beta.
OK, and once we
get to that point,
then now dI/dt is
going to change sign
and will only be negative.
So the number infected
will only be decreasing.
Notice S is strictly
decreasing because this
is a negative rate here.
So S only continues
to go down, which
means that the prefactor
here is always negative.
So the number of infected
people now, at this point,
must also necessarily
continue to go down,
and ultimately the
number of susceptibles
will, from that
point, tend towards 0.
The number of recovered
will tend, of course,
with some lag to S_0.
So this is the
number of recovered.
This is the number
of susceptible.
And the number of
infected, of course,
also goes to 0,
something like this.
And ultimately, in the
long run, the decay--
because S is going to 0,
dI/dt is minus gamma*I*t.
So the final rate of drop
here is -gamma*t.
So basically, the
recovery rate is really
dominating how quickly people
are being converted, basically,
from, to create the
recovered and remove
the infected population.
So the final result here that
comes from these models, which
is quite interesting,
is to ask, what
is this fraction of
the population that
needs to become
immune, or what is
this sort of threshold
of susceptible
in order to achieve
herd immunity?
So if we look at what is
this S_h over the initial?
So how far do we
have to go down?
Well, that would be
gamma/(beta*S_0),
and you'll recognize
that that is
nothing more than the inverse
of the initial reproductive
number.
So essentially, herd
immunity is reached
at a value of the susceptible
fraction becoming 1/R_0.
And this is an
interesting prediction
of this very simple
model, which is
that more infectious
diseases that
have a very high value of
R_0, for example, smallpox,
leads to a situation that,
when the epidemic finally
ends, the number of susceptibles
when you've reached herd
immunity, well, when this
starts to turn around,
is actually quite low.
So, in other words,
you have to go very far
in infecting the population
to start to end the epidemic.
Conversely, a disease that
has a small value of R_0,
even COVID-19, might
be a value of say 3.5,
then this fraction here
might not be so [low].
It might be, maybe,
only say, 20% or 30%.
Where you can start to see then
herd immunity being reached
and the number of infected
people going down dramatically.